the perfect blend of nature and
technology amazon's new headquarters hq2
promises to be the future of corporate
architecture with its innovative
building design and daring style choice
stick with us till the end as we take a
look at this 2.5 billion dollar steel
glass and greenery filled tower
location
being the host of amazon's next big
construction project comes with a ton of
benefits including jobs and increased
visitors keeping these benefits in mind
amazon initially had over 230 proposals
from different cities and states all
across the country following its initial
2017 announcement as you can imagine the
city that never sleeps was selected for
the job and was planned to be the new
site for amazon's latest and greatest
venture in recent times protests this
plan however was quickly scrapped amid
extreme backlash from the local
community there were a number of
protests as amazon faced an onslaught of
criticism over alleged acts of employee
maltreatment according to an xr
spokesperson this action is intended to
draw attention to amazon's exploitative
and environmentally destructive business
practices disregard for workers rights
in the name of company profits following
these protests and clear opposition to
amazon's presence amazon released a
statement saying a number of state and
local politicians have made it clear
that they oppose our presence and will
not work with us to build the type of
relationships that are required to go
forward amazon pulled out leaving mayor
bill de blasio in the wind fighting for
amazon amazon had been promised over 3
billion dollars in incentives for coming
to new york since it would have resulted
in significant long-term progress for
the site it chose according to some
estimates the new headquarters would
have brought over 25 000 jobs and turned
the neighborhood it was placed in into
the next big tech hub
plant life and nature
after new york's offer had been passed
over the next option was arlington west
virginia and that's what amazon has
decided to go with the new amazon hq2
corporate headquarters in crystal city
arlington virginia is an expansion of
the company's headquarters in seattle
washington instead of a replacement of
the existing one this headquarters is
going to act as the center attraction
for all amazon owned and rented
buildings nearby this new headquarters
also called penn palace is going to have
over 2.8 million square feet of office
space with a double helix glass
structure in the center of it all we
need to create unique experience so i
hope it comes alive with human activity
this helix is the main attraction and
instead of a functional office building
it's going to be more recreational
focusing more on biophilia and
increasing productivity via nature and
healthy mental health exercises this is
a growing trend in tech companies and
has been utilized by apple in apple park
and even amazon themselves in their
seattle headquarters in the form of
biodomes lead architect nnbbj the
company amazon has hired to undertake
this daring project principal dale
alberta has said we're doing a lot on
the site to connect people to nature
adding that the design aims to symbolize
both nature and science but with the
helix we really take that to the extreme
we're building a series of indoor
atriums and gardens that are not a
conservatory or a place you just visit
but a place you can actually go and work
amazon has stressed that unlike regular
tech companies that have an aura of
exclusivity and feel fenced off to the
general public penn palace is going to
integrate itself so seamlessly into the
neighborhood that people won't be able
to tell they're in it a lot of focus has
also been dedicated to making penn
palace as environmentally friendly as
possible amazon claims that the building
will run on 100 renewable energy from a
solar farm located 200 miles away in
pennsylvania county south virginia to
further reduce energy consumption the
entire structure has been designed to
make use of as much sunlight as possible
this is to reduce the need for any
artificial lighting in addition to all
this a natural system of ventilation is
also being established using the plants
already planted there talking about
plants professional horticulturists have
been hired to take care of the plants
installed inside and outside pen palace
as for the certification the entire
headquarters is led platinum certified
which is the highest certification a
company can obtain for sustainable
development available from the u.s green
building council
helix structure following the awful pr
disaster amazon had to endure in new
york they've decided to invest more in
public relations and announce that the
project will help with the establishment
of more than thirteen hundred affordable
homes through a two billion dollar fund
to make the site more accessible and
approachable to the public the
groundwork has been so designed to
resemble a futuristic city block instead
of the ground floor of a corporate
organization coming back to the double
helix amazon said the natural beauty of
a double helix can be seen throughout
our world from the geometry of our own
dna to the elemental form of galaxies
weather patterns pine cones and
seashells the helix at our arlington
headquarters will offer a variety of
alternative work environments for amazon
employees amidst lush gardens and
flourishing trees native to the region a
true double helix and shape and
structure this unique building will
feature two walkable paths of landscape
terrain that will spiral up the outside
of the building featuring plantings you
may find on a hike in the blue ridge
mountains of virginia being innovative
and creative is a big part of amazon
resultantly exploring creativity is
especially important in their workplace
to help their employees do just that the
double helix tower acts as a sort of
escape pod for them this
out-of-this-world design and arrangement
of plants right into the very core of
the workplace promotes an environment of
out-of-the-box thinking amazon talked
about this too and because innovative
technology often derives from the
intersection of art and science we've
planned an artist-in-residence program
to be hosted within the helix local
artists in collaboration with our
employees will be inspired by the nature
within the building as they create their
pieces the perfect fusion of nature
architecture intellect and art the
newest headquarters of amazon will be
sporting 2.8 million square feet of
office space across three buildings and
2.5 acres of public space and no it
won't only hog space the company has
confidently claimed that it will be able
to produce 25 000 jobs easily and the
investments can hit as high as 2.5
billion dollars if the queen's office
was a yes from the local politicians the
job count could have gone as high as 50
000 and the investments could have been
doubled that's right it means that
instead of 2.5 billion the investments
would have been 5 billion
features now what will the new campus
have the new campus will not only have
professional sports but in fact there
will be several recreational spaces as
well for example a dog run an
amphitheater for concerts and other
entertainments a decent spot for outdoor
movies and farmers markets etc and if
that wasn't awesome enough already you
can also spot several food trucks around
it and how will the security there be
don't worry you can keep your hopes high
if you're tired of watching movies or
walking your dog you can always go for a
bike ride there will be highly protected
bike lanes and secure entrances not only
food trucks but you'll also find several
shops and restaurants where you can have
one of the potentially best culinary
experiences of your life after all they
are dedicating 100 000 square feet of
space for restaurants shops stalls etc
but why are they putting so much effort
into a building that's mostly going to
be used for work well there is another
aspect of the story that you people
don't know about the designers are
hoping that the new pen palace can be
used as a tourist attraction as well to
create an amazing place for amazon
employees we want it to be vibrant and
we want it to be a destination we want
to be something that the community at
large can be proud of if you think of it
the building is located in just the
right spot right across from the pontiac
river just 15 minutes away if you use
the metro it happens to be at a very
accessible and approachable place by
both employees and visitors unique blend
of innovation architecture nature and
science all in all the newest
headquarters of amazon will cost a
whopping 2.5 billion dollars this unique
blend of innovation architecture nature
and science is going to be a jaw dropper
undeniably the new headquarters also
known as the pen palace will be spread
across 2.8 million square feet of office
space and the building will run on 100
renewable energy from a solar farm the
farm is probably 200 miles away from the
penn palace and honestly this does sound
like an extremely environmentally
friendly and smart move and no the penn
palace won't only have lots of offices
where people will work day and night the
officials have planned to make at least
1300 easily affordable homes and several
other everyday facilities easily
available for the folks there the funds
for the construction of residences are
reaching an astonishingly high mark of 2
billion
and needless to say we are sure that the
houses will be luxurious as well not
only that several recreational sports
and luxuries like dog runs outdoor
movies restaurants cafes will also be
present and if you want to visit
mankind's newest and the most modern
blend of nature art and architecture you
can visit it on weekends as well that's
right ladies and gentlemen the helix
will be open for public tours a few
weekends every month it does sound like
quite an expensive move for the amazon
gods but if it turns out right it can be
one of the biggest marketing successes
that can boost their business
if you liked the video make sure to hit
the like and subscribe button with that
being said peace out